I call this the are you doing here
massive like you guys know where now you
gotta laugh at this but um I've been
watching episodes of the flash I don't
know anyone was here yeah so so I've
been watching and one of the big things
in in that TVs use any many other like
Fabio visas like there's a character and
their masked right their voices like
disguise and a big plot point is who is
that character and then you find out who
it is and there's a you like what are
you doing here I'm not supposed to I
thought you were dead or I thought your
sensors dad Olivia it's all be confusing
right mathematics surprisingly has lots
of moment like that today we're going to
do two of them where when you're looking
at content and we're gonna start d and
you're gonna find something where it's
like what is this doing here this is not
what I expect to see okay so this is
going to happen to us twice I want to
show you what I need okay so you might
like to write this underneath your
vacant heading at the moment you've done
for the most part you done series and
sequences already okay now the main
kinds of series and sequences you focus
on one of the two clients there are two
varieties ApS which grow with a common
difference and GPS we should grow with a
common ratio good then you've got ratios
or rather sequences that don't follow
either of those patterns right so this
is not an 18 or GP is in fact that one
guys on us the afternoon you recognize
this is the Fibonacci sequence to attain
and then 21 and 34 of human natural
sequence it's a famous sequence for a
number of reasons okay
now one of these is why I in until you
that we don't focus on series like these
is because they're actually much harder
to work with even though the building
blocks of this are very simple or what
what is the way that you construct this
series what rule would you explain us on
to get the next number you'd say well if
you want the next number you just take
the two previous ones yes and then if
you want the number after that you just
take the two previous ones so we call
this a recursive definition a recursive
definition it's a definition of this
based on itself right so you've got to
go all the way back through now there is
actually a formula for this series I
want you to raise down with for the nth
Fibonacci number ok now this sequence is
quintessentially about natural numbers
think back to the beginning of complex
numbers we said natural numbers they're
just one two three four five right
that's the kind of building blocks that
you find in this let me show you what
the formula for the Fibonacci sequence
is and you may be a little surprised
okay there with me I have to introduce
some new notation
today remember right I did okay so so
what you're looking at here is a formula
for the nth Fibonacci number all you
have to do in put in n equals 1 2 3 4
100 whatever you like when this Greek
letters I don't know if the Greek letter
is bobbing it's fine ok we're fine is
this particular number over here this
number is very famous it's about 1.6
does anyone know what it is this number
here is the other fresh here okay the
golden ratio is really important you can
go on don't want you to find out all
about it your mind prompted explode I
don't have time to explain it now but my
point is that this sequence is about
natural numbers yes it's a natural
numbers and in order to generate this
sequence with natural numbers for some
reason we have to appeal to irrational
numbers right not even like rational
numbers they've been weird enough
because there are no rational numbers
here we go all the way down the rabbit
hole and you've got square roots in
there what's up with that okay so this
is what i mean by this is just a very
small example of what are you doing here
right like this is what i was expecting
and you dig underneath the surface and
this is what you find okay so that's
weird and I'm going to show that to you
two ways with complex numbers okay so